okay everyone I'm so excited today to be
reviewing Mike flannan's newest Netflix
show and his last Netflix show as he is
moving over to Amazon Prime The Fall of
the House of Usher I'm going to be
reviewing every single episode in detail
of this show right now but please note
make sure you've watch the whole season
first this is going to be spoiling the
whole season I'm going to be talking
about the end of the show even when I'm
talking about the first couple episodes
so make sure to watch the full season
first as your last warning now what
stuck out to me just from the start of
watching the show was this was the best
cast Mike Flanigan show he has a lot of
usual names usually has in his
repertoire and he's good at giving them
consistent work they're great actors and
I wish a lot of them had more work
elsewhere too but it's always good to
see them here but I always say in some
of my reviews Mike Flanigan's work
there's sometimes I feel like he has one
or two characters he miscasts like I had
said about midnight mass I thought that
Kate seagull was miscast in her part but
here she is playing the perfect
character for her I did not find any
flaws here the only one I was hesitant
at first was Henry Thomas playing the
character of Freddy but as is showing on
you realized why he was playing the
character Freddy and how perfect he
actually was for the part and what's
even crazier is that Bruce Greenwood
plays older rodri and he actually
replaced Franklin Jella who got in some
trouble here so it actually worked out
for the better because I couldn't see
anyone else besides Bruce Greenwood
playing rodri that's what I thought was
Flawless in the casting too especially
with meline in the different ages and
how similar she felt and looked in each
age range I was so impressed with that
and I mean there's so much to praise
here with the acting so we'll get into
all that while we go through the episode
so let's start with episode one of
midnight Dre this was directed and
written by Mike Flanigan now with all
his shows when you watch it a second
time you get so much more out of it and
that's even with the opening shot he's
opening with another brick in the wall
and this is alluding to that important
wall here that we now know Rufus
Griswald is put in and that is where he
will die and you hear the jester bells
in the first shot of the show so it's
giving you these big hints and how
important this wall would be and it's
that important New Year's Eve and it's
cool just knowing verna's name and that
she's revealed later on to be the raven
that Verna is an anagram of the word The
Raven so that was your big hint
obviously and also in the posters with
her having a raven mask now you actually
see when Roger is thinking at the
funeral about his children's deaths you
see a montage of all their deaths you
get the quickest Glimpse but you see
just in the base form how they're all
going to look when they're facing their
death which I thought was really cool
and you right away are going to feel
like that inspiration from succession
here this show felt like a horror
version of succession where it really
felt like that not only in the look and
feel of it and talking about wealth and
bad people also in the music really a
lot of the piano pieces are clearly
inspired by the music succession was
recently using now what grips you from
the start is meeting Auggie dupan and
him being told to come literally to the
House of Usher and this is where he will
talk with rodri and rodri's going to
narrate us through all his children's
deaths and what has happened to them now
maybe where the biggest leeway in the
story and suspension of disbelief here
is that the excuse he has that he knows
how all this happened to every child is
they eventually told him in spirit form
okay like even in the rules of this show
it's a little much and a little easy but
that was probably one of my small gripes
with that but otherwise I I think that
all still lines up really well and I
just absolutely loved watching older
Auggie with older rodri talking every
moment with them was so good and that's
also a props not only to Bruce Greenwood
but also to Carl lumbley who's also
great you probably recognize him from
Falcon of the Winter Soldier recently
and then you notice on second watch that
same bottle of liquor that Verna had is
the same one that rer is holding knowing
then that it is his last night on earth
or it's what you drink when it's your
best night of your life so really
interesting we see both versions of that
for rodri and he mentions meline is
downstairs in the basement and then you
know where that's going to turn but when
you're first watching the show that is
what's adding the Intrigue here and
sucking you in now what also stood out
to me about the show right away which
gave me such relief was the hardest
thing I was on about midnight mass was
how long the monologues were he did this
in blind manner as well in Midnight Mass
it was completely overboard where just
go on and on and on he fixed it here so
well where every time there was a
monologue it was perfectly edited
perfectly stopped at the right time that
kept the rhythm going and didn't stop
the flow of the show it's what made this
one to me really be up there with the
levels of Haunting of Hill House I'm so
impressed at how they fix that now I
love this line where Rodrick says I
called you tonight to give you only
thing you ever wanted my confession so
we see that tape recorder and that's
going to be important because that's
going to become so important to be the
payoff at the end of this show when
Auggie is looking at the grave and has a
tape recordered there and doesn't even
want it anymore he doesn't want the
confession he doesn't care about it
anymore which I love and we'll break
more into why I love that and the
message of that when we get to that in
the final episode and that's why it's so
important that in this first episode he
starts with talking about 1953 at the
beginning of his life with him and
meline these two twins he's like you
cannot understand the things I've done
unless you understand the life that
meline and I were born into this was so
important because you see this in shows
times they try to build sympathy with
the character but what I believe the
show is doing was showing you that
trying to trick you down that similar
route like oh maybe we'll start to feel
for Roger but I think they're showing
you you're supposed to feel for him and
feel for mine upbringing of course but
it's showing you people who choose to do
the same thing to others and be evil and
almost use it as an excuse and that you
shouldn't and I I really appreciate they
put all this effort to show that now I
love when you even see little meline she
is from the start the one that is
pushing all the moves she is The
Mastermind beh all this and really gets
the worst out of rodri whenever she can
and brings that out in him when you
really look back at this story meline
Ric really are you're just watching the
life and the decisions and why they do
the things they do and why you shouldn't
really sympathize with these people that
are really just two antagonists at the
end of the day of this show and how they
connect so well throughout the show that
rodri would learn from people as a child
of William Longfellow who his mother
killed and what's crazy about that is
that meline will kill him the same way
his mom killed William Longfellow who
was really his dad and that it's showing
you he replaced that version of William
Longfellow and he also imitates a lot
Rufus Griswald who's another version of
William Longfellow rodri just became the
man he hated and said literally word for
word lines that they had said throughout
the show which I thought was fascinating
and I love seeing Lulu Wilson another
Flanigan Allstar from Haunting Phil
house she also in a great great movie
Becky you should check out but it was
good she got a part here and I love the
young actor who plays young rodri looks
exactly like Zack gilfred I don't know
how they do this but they did a great
job and this really establishes this
flashback how their relationship works
meline and Rodrick and that was the most
important thing to make this show really
work and they do such a good job with
that and you also get the Edward Allen
Poe writing blending in starting right
around here when they're talking about
the mom being buried alive now when they
realize their mom left the ground I mean
something about this visually was like
the best lightning I've ever seen on
screen I thought it just looked so real
and I like it gets the grandfather clock
swinging just a little foreshadowing
about Freddy and that pendulum and as
this Premiere goes on we learn about
liadon and the opioid epidemic and the
mountain of corpses that piled up since
painkillers were marketed and how much
rodri is responsible for this and that
Augie had this great move to take down
people that don't go to prison like them
they always talk about that that these
people are Prett predicted and we'll
really know why too because of Verna but
also we know in real life this is the
case as well but his smart move was to
pin them against each other by saying
there was an informant now what's
interesting is in this episode we get a
little introduction to all the children
and their relationships and how they
abuse cheat use people and when you
watch the show in a second watch you
realize to these are children that
weren't bad when they were growing up
but the money changed all of them and
Roger really fed and fed them until they
weren't Rich anymore more in the way
that Annabelle Lee sees being rich of
just being Joy innocent happy instead of
the riches of just wealth that can
corrupt people so they did a good job
with that too and following through with
that and I love that we see Pluto the
Cat come home in this episode where I
believe this was already Verna preparing
her kill of Napoleon as you watch these
children die one by one to Verna I see
it more as they're getting more gruesome
deaths because of the choices they're
making that she's always saying to them
you still have time not to do this they
were all going to die anyway that was
part of the deal but it's how they go
out there's some kind of entity behind
verer as her being like a grim reaper
just doing her job being a structure for
order that there was more gruesome of a
death due to somebody who did worse
things and speaking of erer this really
is best role Carla Gino has ever played
it is perfectly cast and I'm so happy we
get to see her shine because she hasn't
really gotten the role yet since
haunting Phi house in the lore of the
Flanigan universe that's been as good as
haunting Phil house or even Gerald's
Game this was just so great to see and I
love we get such an introduction to us
as the audience of how this meline
behaves when she straight up tells all
the children at the informant when they
find out who it is they'll be killed and
Roger even puts a bounty on the
informant and that they'll give whoever
finds him 50 million and I love this
little dialogue where in present day
Augie's like saying to Roger you're not
implying that me saying someone was
informant caused all your kids deaths
and he's like I am responsible but we'll
get to that a little later and he's like
more to the point there's a woman a
woman I have to tell you about which we
know is Verna and I love in this bar
when we see them originally meet Verna
you got the murials of the black cat
which is going to be whole episode EDG
gr and po the black cat and the Raven
which be whole episode in the finale
just the egg gr and po Easter eggs in
generals great and by them putting Rufus
Griswald in the wall and killing him
this is a choice they made with a direct
consequence of why they met Verna that
night and I love when they order the
drinks she says buy now pay later that's
her motto and that's exactly how Verno
works as well and you see how rodri says
him and meline have the same resolution
they're going to change the world and
this is something they're so said on and
they'll talk about this through the show
that they just focus on the immediate
needs and what their goals are what they
want to do and not how they affect
people around them and you love seeing
when Roger's at the funeral here of his
children he looks up and he sees Verna
in The Raven mask again making it
obvious she's the Raven and it ends him
facing the jester in a great jump scare
in the limo reminds you of the jester
from Ari fr the dark and he collapses
and he faces The Raven he says it's time
so you're getting a glimpse of these
important scenes that are going to be in
the finale that come back full circle so
it's a great opening episode it's a
great setup and it really sucks you in
right away and you're like okay this is
like legit legit like here we go so I'm
giving this Premiere a 9.2 episode 2 is
titled the mask of the Red Death this
was directed against by Mike Flanigan
and written by Mike Flanigan again but
with Emmy grinwis now this is where we
start seeing one by one the deaths of
the children now as we watch this I
really enjoyed these episodes but I will
say what I prefer the most and was the
best to me out of the show was the
premiere and the second to last and the
finale because they weren't so focused
on that formula approach even though yes
the one before the finale was about
Freddy there was a lot more to it and I
think my only big criticism of the show
but it still didn't really affect me
that much and how much I enjoyed it was
that it did start to feel a little
repetitive and predictable at a point
and that's going to come with a
territory but the end of the day it
still feels that way right so I think
that hurted a little bit for me but not
much but just going through the motions
okay you know who's going to die you
pretty much get the gist of how they're
going to die pretty early on too almost
too heavy foreshadowing but still really
enjoyable so let's go into the first one
that's like this and this is going to be
the Perry death episode and going to
first meet dupan when he was younger in
1979 and he's on to Rufus Griswald what
he's doing and what the Corruptions
these drug trials and there's even
Graves being robbed he's like people
supposed to make us healthy make us sick
the world needs changing now he says the
world needs changing but he means it in
a good way compared to what rodri and
meline mean now it was interesting that
in the present day auggie's telling
rodri the use of lione and causing
overdoses highly addictive and that he
knew it was highly addictive rodri and
marketed non addictive anyway and that
was the greed that was there and he's
like was it ever going to be enough you
could have stopped at what you were
making not marketing it that way and
it's never enough and it really was
interesting watching Auggie confront
this man and what he's done through his
life and what made me love how they WRA
this up eventually with Roger and Augie
that it's not your typical oh Roger
comes around and is remorseful and gets
what he did like he owns it like he's
like I knew that's his big confession
that he knew was going to be bodies
piled up here to get what he wanted to
get this glorious lifestyle to be like a
pharaoh and to be all powerful and greed
and didn't care that's what he knew was
the cost and he was willing to pay it
and it just shows you that is at the end
of the day what a bad person really can
think like and be and it's terrifying
that's the real horror of the show but I
thought that was so effective now it's
cool we see the children haunting them
in the each of their episodes in the
present day where Prospero starts
haunting them here now it's interesting
Prospero is obsessed with orgies and
drugs and he's upset that his father
doesn't take him seriously about his
plan about this club he wants to have
and it's crazy looking back when you
watch this again because they literally
say in a board meeting that proro is in
that testing facilities they own are
leaking toxins into the groundwater and
if he had just listened to that part in
the meeting he probably wouldn't have
faced that exact fate he faced at the
end with the spring glares and when you
see Mark Ham on the show to me when he's
playing Pim it's very Mike trout type
presentation of this character this role
it's the guy just gets the job done with
a straight face and doesn't ask
questions he just protects and covers
things up now I love that the children
would see in their choices they making
more and more Verna coming along and
Verna observing what their choices are
to kind of determine how gruesome their
death will be and getting to talk to
them which I loved and him seeing Vera
right when he goes to that old fac
facility on the rooftop and he's already
making bad choices we know at the end of
the episode he's really also doing this
to make blackmail on famous people but
also on his brother and it is one of
those things where a great lesson about
this show and how well it shows you is
like people are getting wronged by each
other here but it's not the solution to
then also wrong somebody else that's
still a choice we're all making and
there's no excuse for that which I
really loved cuz you could go oh yeah
prospal Jing this to somebody who is not
good either but that doesn't make it
right and I think the show's loudly
telling you that in a good way now I
like they start sprinkling in other
stuff happening with other children like
victorine pumping chimps here with
adrenaline to get the results she wants
so you're just getting a little
breadcrumbs of like what is going on
with everyone else as well and they're
also developing Camille on The Witch
Hunt here for victorine being the
informant and you already see her
assistant which is midnight club Alum
here saying that what did she do to you
why do you hate her so much and that's
said to her a lot so that will get
payoff in her episode which we'll talk
about but when we're talking about the
comparisons to succession Prospero is
very Kendall Roy to me in this episode
he's like Make It Rain about the
sprinklers and wanting all this party to
be perfect and just totally improvises a
lot of things now what's interesting is
that rodri in the present day will bring
up cat assol and it's hereditary form of
vascular cognitive impairment before
kills you causes symptoms very much like
dementia and there's no cure and that's
why he's like don't kid a kid her but
the heart mesh that he wanted Victory to
make was to buy time it's more
preventative and it' be something he
could sell now this is very fasing the
whole cat assol idea in the show because
it plays Mike Flanigan likes to do
because they're Supernatural here but
there's also parts of this form of
dementia running through this family and
that when they're all snapping in and
out of it that you could say parts of it
is that genetic dementia kicking in but
at the same time it really is Verna
possessing them or haunting them in ways
so they like to toy with you there and
you can take it how you want but I
always find that's very interesting and
Flanigan's the best at that and then we
see in the flashback what's so important
is when rodri is pitching Rufus Griswald
is liadon and remember he loves liadon
he loves literally liadon who is the
form of Juno played by the great Ruth
Cod from Midnight Club that is when he
again says it again this world needs
changing to Rufus so you're just seeing
his intentions here he's like fortunado
will be a miracle this is how you change
the world but he does bring up his mom
was in pain Agony he's like you make
billions doing this but that's not why
you do it but this is where he was at
this point rodri but he's not fully down
the dark path yet you got to wait for
meline to really bring that out in him
and that's where he's interesting in the
past pulled between the side of
Annabelle and meline and Auggie and that
mine at the end of the day is going to
pull him more more to his dark side that
was already in him it's like that demon
vers Angel decision on a shoulder and
she's always leaning that demon way and
gets that out of him I also want to just
mention with Annabelle Katie Parker what
I talked about with the great casting
here this was her best Flanigan role I
wasn't a fan of her haunting a Hill
House the character she was playing I
didn't think it worked but for her here
she was amazing so again really shines
how well this was just knocked out here
with the casting and this is where we'll
see he says Edgar alen po po about
Annabelle Lee which I loved his true
love and this is really important into
his choice and how he chose this lavish
Empire and greed and success and power
over who his true love was in Annabelle
Lee so this is really showing you how
effectively Mike Flanigan Blended in aen
pose works with this modern story I also
love that meline here loves his ideas of
algorithms of course and even it can
write TV shows and movies so that's a
very timely thing to bring up but this
is where Annabell Le says to meline
aren't there some things only sad people
can do not these algorithms and yeah
that's alluding to edar Poe himself and
his talent that can't be replicated but
also rodri because we know he was a
great poet and that he could have gone
that route of the poor poet and not this
life of corruption and power and it's
crazy because then in the present
timeline we actually see the older
meline takes Leno's Journal at one point
to use for the bot version of Lenor
which gets his insane payoff of being
the bot that is texting rodri at the end
of this show but you see they're
obsessed with immortality the ushers and
comparing to Egyptians and these
immortality collections they have and I
love they show meline showing the pick
here they would use to take out of the
brain before mummification and to me
this is what she's planning to do with
AI now a great humorous moment is when
Lenor walks in on Juno and rodri and she
says oh hello grandpa and grandma and
Juno's like no never again that was
great but we learn how they met and that
Juno was in a brutal car accident and
it's crazy they wanted rodri to see her
cuz she was on a dosage of lione no one
was ever on and she was conscience and
this is great later on this little story
because he looks at her as the monster
and he's Dr Frankenstein really really
awesome now we also see in these bad
choices that Perry is making that he
goes to reel in Freddy's wife cuz he
hates Freddy anyway and is just luring
her like hey I still see that fiery free
spirited goddess in there and she's like
how dare you I'm your brother's wife and
he's like yeah that's pretty hot and he
actually gets it out of her but you have
to understand with the character of Mory
is that she was tempted to cheat but she
didn't and this is the false claim that
Freddy thinks she did so that leads to
Absolute chaos which we'll get into but
you got to remember that here she didn't
actually cheat at this club now now
we'll also get a little hint about tamy
here played by the great Samantha slow
and another case of just I wish she got
more work outside of flang and she's so
good and he always gives her great parts
and you knew seeing her that Tammy was
just going to be awful like an awful
person she's so good at playing those
type of characters and we see she has
this prostitute come over to roleplay
with her husband and she gets off on it
so you're already kind of fascinated
about what the hell is going on here and
then we get a little time with Camille
and we learn that our assistants have
another use besides just doing their
daily duties as assistants I mean Kate
seagull is amazing in this part and
hysterical she was the funniest part of
the show to me I thought this was a
perfect part for was so exciting to see
her play a character like this now I
love when we get to this big club scene
that Verno walks in with this skull mask
that she's eventually going to put on
Perry and I love when Perry goes into
the room and first sees Verna laying
there in the bed you bet your ass the
way she was sitting on that bed was a
nod to her starring in Mike Flanigan's
Gerald game and she says is it
everything you wanted it to be and he
said not yet almost and she says nearly
realized is the sweetest it's better I
promise in the moment just before than
in the moment after that is the truth of
the world just fascinating writing here
and she said there's still time to stop
it and she's like things like this all
things in fact have consequences and
brings up how he was the consequence of
a harmless Choice by someone a moment
where you didn't even exist talking
about rodri having him with a woman on
the whim she's like we could have had
fun you and me and I think this just a
disappointment in him knowing she was
having to kill him but there could have
been a better way out with all this with
him and he's just as dirty as the rest
of the ushers and you knew the
sprinklers were going to be the doom and
I loved hearing the 9in nails closer
here that got me pumped up and you see
Verna even warns Mory to leave
unfortunately she doesn't get out and
the acid comes down the lights are
flickering it was amazing to N9 nails so
so good in a horror aspect of it it and
you see Perry looks like vcna at this
point so really strong second episode
I'm going to give this one an 8.7 okay
so we're going to go to episode three
now murder in the RoR this was directed
by Michael fonari and written by Mike
Flanigan and Justina Ireland now Michael
fuminari has done a lot of
cinematography for Mike Flanigan and his
directing in this show blew me away and
how good it was you're living up to
someone like Mike Flanigan's directing
and you have another person here who's
coming into their own as a director and
he absolutely kills it in this show I
was really impressed with that so this
the first episode we see he directs and
it's going to remind a lot of people of
the recent Jordan Peele film nope with
the chimps here and you see what's cool
about this show is you're hearing the
sounds of what's going to cause the Doom
of whoever child's dying in that episode
in the beginning with the black on the
screen I thought that was great we hear
the chimp noises here and it's so sad
also when you see Pim go goes to the
crime scene of where Perry died and he
finds Mory is still alive but watching
this on second watch at that moment
you're like you know what she's probably
better off dead than what she's going to
suffer with Freddy but you see how these
children really are because when Perry
dies Freddy runs to the hospital and
Roger's like did you hear me your
brother's dead he's like yeah Perry's
dead got it doesn't care and Camille is
just worried about the pr of all this it
really shows you their characters and
how nasty they can be and she just wants
to take this as opportunity to build
Sympathy for the family and there's a
great line Camille has here where she's
like that's why we have a charity Wing
so we can past someone's face on it when
we need it and she even has the gall to
connect all the opioid losses to grieve
to we grieve with you we know loss what
interesting though you see rodri is
fully blaming Freddy on this death of
Perry he's like CU you didn't take the
building down this is you did this but
you're seeing that rodri is in denial
right now at this point he's not fully
processing like what happened with Verna
yet yet and that this could be coming
true his deal see I almost wish camil
was in the show longer cuz she was so
good here and she's like Toby damn it
everybody knows that Edible Arrangements
are what you send to people you hate
that was so good and you'll see which
was fascinating that Vern is already
planting herself to different children
early on even though it might not be
their episode to die like she plants
herself early on to victorine and we get
to see Carlo guino have just so much fun
here she gets to do different accents
and you get to see her acting arrange I
mean this is that kind of role actor's
dream of getting and she delivers and
get getting that part and you see
victorine is getting interested in her
cuz she knows she's the perfect
candidate to do the human trials on With
This Heart mesh now I love this line
that Camille's honest about the BS about
her family that they all use someone
else's idea there's no Talent there they
just spin stuff they don't actually make
anything she's like ushers don't make
stuff I'm like a ceiling fan that just
spins and doesn't go anywhere it's so
good now what's interesting is that
Camille when she first haunts rodri here
in the present she gives him a soldier R
I actually wish they didn't show that
because it made it too set up for the
jump scare later on that was really
intense I I wish I didn't even have her
on my mind yet with the jump scare so
that was an odd decision by me for the
horror aspect of the show I rather just
did the jump scare so that really I
think would be more effective without
having her on your mind yet but you see
rodri saying to Auggie don't imply it
was my drug and that I killed him with
his drug talking about them finding a
version of lione in Perry's system he's
like I didn't design it he says he's a
middleman never my drug it's the
complete hypocrisy of rodri here and the
denial part of it that he can push it
down when it's convenient that it's not
his drug now all of a sudden and it cuts
clearly to the pass of him saying this
is my drug that was great but you see
ruus gisell just takes liadon from him
in his idea and owns it and he gives him
gratitude he's like I'll give you a
promotion $500 check he says money for a
brain fart but this is where my possibly
top three performance there's so many
good ones in the show but Willow
Fitzgerald as meline was such an
important thing that if she didn't nail
it like she did it could collapse this
whole show if they had casted someone
who was over the top with Mader and just
didn't hit that Nuance like she did and
she was perfect here I was amazed and it
really started showing when she has this
important scene with rodri and brings up
their foster parents and how rodri was
defiant with them and that didn't work
he got locked in a closet for it so
she's like meline herself went the other
way would kiss up to them play them and
then she would get them and throw them
under the bus so she's like she didn't
know it was me until they had her foster
parents in cuffs she's comparing that to
Rufus griswell that they have to do the
same thing with him and she mentions how
the more you fight the more bricky will
add till you're in your own tiny little
tomb so that's going to literally be
what they put Rufus Griswald in which
was amazing and you see Annabelle
hearing all this is freaked out you know
she's a normal person who gets this is
psychotic thing thing to say and you see
you know the red flags are there for
Annabelle she says at night to rodri I
know she's had it hard both of you do
but I don't like her honey I'm sorry I
don't and this again goes to like can't
have excuses for this Behavior either
you had it hard but you're obviously not
in the right mindset now also happening
this episode is that Leo blacked out his
apartment and he killed his boyfriend's
cat and I believe this was already Verna
because she'll be wearing a similar
collar when she's in human form that was
on the cat now maybe the scariest scene
in the show to me was actually when
Lenor goes to see her mom for the first
time in the hospital and she's ripping
off the bandages that was just
terrifying cuz it felt very real now the
funniest part hands down of the show and
the probably top five scene for me is
when Camille's assistants come and tell
her that they're in love and Kate
seagull's reaction is amazing she's like
you to Fell in Love Tina one month after
I finished paying off your student Deb
Tina and she's like my name isn't Tina
it's B
that was so good and she goes I don't
give a [__] Beth and the funniest line
of the show is when she says Camille
when the north anrin wears off and the
two of you are laying in bed next to
each other and one of you lets out a
long fart in your sleep you're going to
look back at this moment and realize
what a stupid decision you both just
made I fell over laughing that was a
funny sign in any Mike Flanigan work I I
was just like I wish we got more Camille
at this point you know just great and
then we also get to see
planting herself to Tammy and meets
Tammy as candy The Prostitute who's
going to sub in for her other prostitute
and her she Aces the imitation here
she's perfect as Tammy and of course
Tammy is going to get off on this but
props to Carlo guino nailing that and
we'll see Camille will meet Verna at the
security guard at Rue see I love when
Verna says to her why do you hate her
talking about Camille hating victorine
she's like on paper you should have been
allies the bastard Daughters of rodri
Usher what an alliance you could have
made and Verna jumps on the table and is
like connecting to The Chimps here which
was crazy and again Caro Cina just out
of this world here and she's like you
pick the worst job to hide your true
nature you clean up dirt for a living
where Victor on the other side didn't
she looks like to Mother Teresa on the
outside but inside though she's like you
two are the most like you hate her
because she hit it better this was
awesome and I love also she gets these
lines in like you lot can't make a
lipstick or dandruff shampoo without
making something self for talking about
the animal testing she's like I love how
deliciously pointlessly mean you lot can
be and Verna really is a conduit for the
chimp is like you're right she lies
talking about victorine and she pumps Us
full of adrenaline to make it look like
it works so she's admitting like yeah
victorine deserves this what you're
about to do to her but it doesn't
justify you doing the wrongful act she's
like you didn't have to come here though
you could have happened quiet peaceful
in bed but a guess has to happen like
this because of her choice to do
something like this this and she's
mauled by The Chimps you know like yeah
if she didn't choose to do a nasty thing
back to nasty people which isn't the
solution she could have died peacefully
in bed but she didn't and you love
hearing the chimps and the credits
brutal I do wish we got a little more
intensity with actual visual with the
chimps Ming her but okay that's fine
maybe I said I'm not saying that but I
still loved it and this was a really
really solid episode I'm going to give
this one a nine I just wish we got more
Camille but that's just not against show
but that's just me as a fan just so much
fun to watch Kate Seagle have fun here
okay now episode four the black cat was
again directed by Michael fumari who
does a great job again and it's written
by Mike Flanigan and Matt Johnson this
time so it's one of my favorite episodes
and you start with the cat noises you're
like oh no like here we go and you see
Leo is with Verna who has a collar
unlike the cat and he wants a
replacement Black Cat and it's
interesting that she says I have a soft
spot for the short timers always have
this was to me a little foreshadowing
about her feeling so sad about having to
kill Lenor who was very young and very
innocent now I also want to mention that
it really to me was already Verna taking
over that first cat because it wasn't
him killing the cat that was what got
him in trouble and having a more
gruesome death to me it was him already
cheating on his boyfriend without
telling him when that cat was going to
come into that apartment so that's what
a took as his choices and then
eventually lying about killing the cat
and covering it up to his boyfriend all
these just bad choices by Leo and you
see when Leo gets the news that
Camille's dead he just can't believe it
he's in complete denial and this is
where rodri and the president's talking
about sometimes things do go away on
their own so it makes it feel like
denial works it's the placebo effect and
we'll see this when Roger first season
hands picked of Verna and that he's in
denial about who that really is and I
love they still check in with the sounds
in the basement he's like oh it's just
meline that was great you see how cruel
Tammy is in the boardroom scene where
Juno says sorry to Tammy about losing
Camille and she's like why is it talking
it shouldn't be talking right now brutal
now also Maddie was in denial at the
beginning with these photos of Verna but
she does go to the bar site sees it was
a graffitied wall and there's no bar
there and she's like this is crazy don't
be stupid meline and you see the Raven
art on it and the Raven comes to see her
and we also see at this moment rodri
first goes back to that wall where they
put Rufus Griswald in and hears those
Jester Bells so the curiosity is there
could this really be happening in their
both their minds and just speaking about
things that happen that are messed up
and that this family was doing you see
Verna says to victorine that
pharmaceutical companies are known to
test on humans in poor countries that
may not be aware of the side effects
victorine spins this as it gives people
treatment they couldn't otherwise afford
again going to this denial theme now it
was really cool show shot when Leo was
in bed with jeweles is that he sees the
cat's eyes glowing in the dark which is
Verna just like the Raven and he starts
getting the gifts the dead rat under the
pillow what's interesting in the present
day is there is a moment when they bring
up when they first met Auggie and rodri
in the past and you see rodri's reaction
to learning about the forge signatures
of himself and he's like I don't recall
and Auggie sees right through he's like
look your good parents who can't afford
the medicine can't afford to say the
wrong thing hard to say the wrong thing
but even harder to do the right thing so
this is going to be full circle too
because it's that decision you make here
and that's going to come to a Crossroads
later on with rodri and his decision to
not keep with Augie's plan and betray
him and it's interesting when rodri is
confronting Rufus in the past about the
forge signature this is when Rufus gives
him the speech about you being a team
player and to keep quiet and this is
about forming a wall he says I'm the
commanding officer all I want to hear is
sir yes sir this is the same line rogi
will say as older rodri at the start of
this episode to his kid so again that
reflection of him becoming the man he
hated and he says Rufus to him you
follow my lead keep your mouth shut and
he comp Compares himself to Willy Wonka
he's like you're Charlie Bucket and to
me the show also has a Willy Wonka thing
going on because you're seeing the kids
hitting Doom at the end just like Le
Wonka now Leo sits on the dead bird now
there's a dead mouse in his shoe and
Verna shows up and she's like cats are
predators it's in their jeans they were
domesticated 10,000 years ago but that
prey drive it's there this is such a
cool scene and scary scene and I love
that during this we see Thor's hammer in
the background and this is that rule of
check off's gun right like if you're
going to show something like that you
better use it and thank God they did
because that was sticking out to him
like okay why is that there and it gets
such a good payoff with him actually
using Thor's hammer here and he even
says he got it from Hemsworth and what
you're watching this was either one
thinking like how amazing car Gina would
be as a Catwoman and I love she says
that they're Predators because they're
deficient and she's a lot like your
father aren't they Leo and you see when
he pushes one eye out of the cat her eye
comes out connecting that and that she's
the cat really cool horror effect now we
also learned that the doc came by at one
point to rodri and told him he had
catell same as his mom did and it's in
an advanced stage and that he's
attributing hallucinations to that
because he sees the dead Perry version
haunting him now Jules comes home to Leo
going nuts over this cat with Thor's
hammer in his hand and remember this
whole episode Jules doesn't ever see
this replacement cat and that he doesn't
see him in this moment either but Leo
does and it's Verna and that she's
baiting him to jump off the ledge and I
love that when he jumps off the ledge it
cuts to the tub where all the prey go of
this cat so he's just part of that now
and we see Verna to me being also Pluto
shows up here getting that sweet revenge
that was a great ending moment probably
one of the best endings of any of these
episodes so 9.1 for me on that one okay
so episode 5 is The Telltale Heart this
was directed by Mike Flanigan and
written by Danny Parker it's the only
episode not also at any point written by
Mike Flanigan now this episode opens
with the heart pumping sound and hearing
the Flies so you know this is the dead
heart of victorine's Lover now it's
interesting verus says to rodri on New
Year's Eve about Ravens not bad Omens in
every culture a lot of people believe
Ravens bring good fortune and they do in
the show they ended this evil bloodline
of the ushers now you'll see even Augie
infers that New Year's Eve is when
things went to crap with rodri and
Annabelle even though he is kissing this
other woman for a reason to show face
and an alibi he's also probably right in
this statement and you see how Rog looks
at the funeral of his other Mistresses
he doesn't even acknowledge them or
console them it reminds me a lot of
succession in that shot we saw at the
funeral where you see all the mistresses
is of Logan Roy it's so tragic watching
this over too because you'll notice with
myy in the hospital that she was on the
up and up the doctor was saying when
Freddy decides to take her home and do
what he does to her so really brutal now
we learned victorine did not tell
alisandra about the big surgery she's
going to do next week and she's telling
her like look can't back out we have to
do this it's human trials now there's
$200 million of rodri Usher money here
and we learned she forged a signature to
clear the use of the Prototype heart mes
this is so ethical and Alexandre is like
I'm going to squeal about it she's like
you ushers you're all monsters and we
see victorine hits her in the back of
the head but this cuts to Black the
first time so you don't know exactly
what happened yet and now back at the
office you'll see she hears the chirping
she's already made this horrible choice
of throwing this item we now know at the
back of alexandre's head and has her
literally with the heart mesh on at the
apartment already like insane but goes
to work still now in the present Auggie
will reveal to rodri there was no
informant but he's like like I never
imagin the kids would start dying he was
just trying to pit them against each
other and Roger has this moment of like
just denial and snaps like into a
different place he like if it weren't
for you they would all still be alive
today which leads to a very intense
scare one of the bests of Auggie
bleeding through his shirt and then
victorine's head replaces it terrifying
but that's where you see Roger comes to
S he's like Auggie let me relieve you of
that burden no one died for your life so
don't carry that one had nothing to do
with the other and he says the mind of
guilt is full of scorpions and I would
wish that sting on anybody so it's maybe
one of the few likable moments of Roger
giving Auggie that peace of mind there
you also get a scene here where Griswald
is just completely being a creep to
meline putting her down and her way she
sticks up for herself to Griswald you
learn more about meline how she says to
Verner doesn't want to have a man have
power over her and then figure out how
to live forever being her vision and her
dream and the way he's talking to her
about her mom you just sense like this
was the nail in the coffin for him in
mine's plan and killing him now a little
thing you got to catch is Freddy had a
bouquet of flowers for myy when he
brought her home and Lenora brings in
growing plant to myy and she's like who
wants to watch their favorite flower die
slowly and aase this is saying it all
Freddy does Freddy's watching myy die
slowly and is enjoying it now Tammy also
see her paranoia goes more and more
towards her husband Bill about him
sleeping with who we know is Verna and
she's just cruel to him she's like I
chose you from a list you fit the brand
you're a product mask got asset and Bill
will leave after this fight now there's
an interesting moment where rodri is
looking at the wall they put Griswald in
and he says maybe I'm losing my mind
dementia is a nasty little [__] or
maybe this crazy BS is right maybe I
know how to stop it so he's thinking
okay if I OD on lione then my kids will
live no one else is going to die from
that deal but he can't do it he's a
coward he says and he's like 10 seconds
you'd save them all thinking of jumping
off the building it's interesting rodri
apologizes to victorine about pitting
the kids against each other he's like I
wanted to make you stronger and I was
wrong but you feel like he's just saying
this cuz he needs something from her he
needs that heart patch and he's like I
may need your work more than you know
willing to go all in but this is where
he sees and hears the heart as she turns
off the music and this will lead into
showing what really happened with
victorine and her lover and that she had
this choice where she could have at
least still called 911 and couldn't have
that secret get out though she can't go
to jail she's like this was an accident
you hear me just denial again you see
she's like I forgot and it shows her
holding that surgical knife just crazy
scene and you see rodri now opens the
door Sees the heart MH device on the
heart of Alexandre it's like okay it
works you know the device it's pumping
and that's where ver is like it's just
pumping a dead useless heart she says
she takes over victorine and she says
wish you dumped maybe I wouldn't have to
do this but who am I kidding and
alluding that just wouldn't work and she
stabs victorine chest as victorine in
front of rodri and she says daddy and
you love hearing and the heart pumping
in the credits so solid solid horror
there so I'm give this one a nine now
episode six is gold bug this was
directed by Mike Flanigan and written by
Rebecca kingle now this episode to me
was my least favorite only because I
felt like it suffered the most of
predictability and feeling that
repetition now a lot where I was kind of
like okay let's get a little bit more on
with this it was a little too
telegraphed for me but youve seen the
beginning you hear the class shattering
and you know how that's going to end and
it does have an amazing ending shot
which we're going to get to but you're
questioning right because Tammy's
forgetting a lot here a lot of tapping
in and out where you could say it's
Verna you could say maybe it's that
dementia kicking in but you see it's
everything's green here with Tammy green
Walls green dress greed money this is
representing you even have the green
lights and that'll eventually be all
green lights in a room later on the
green necklace later on and she's first
trying to go to sleep that night before
her big presentation she looks at the
glass ceiling which will be her Doom but
meline in this time now is reminding
rodri that victorine was on the board
which is not good and she's like if we
don't find woman from the bar we'll lose
the family and the company but rodri's
so obsessed with finding out about how
we can control the board he's still in
denial about the Verna part it's there
but he's still trying to choose denial
but meline is accepting it meline knows
like okay this is the problem this is
happening now what's actually sad here
with Tammy is that there's a moment
where her husband bill says you not okay
you're not alone in this I'm with you
and I love you that definitely happened
and she says back to him I don't but she
actually had a moment where she did
answer him but it was too late you wish
she said this answer to him where she
said she wants the world to see they
aren't just pill pushers us your name
more than just rodri and meline and she
says I'm scared Bill she's actually
honest with him it was it was too late
the key was there he was actually there
but she says it after the fact so all
for not you see how selfish this family
could be where Lenor will literally tell
Roger something is off with her dad and
she's scared and he's literally just
doesn't care and that's when she's like
are you okay cuz he's just quote Nar
alen Poe it's also interesting that Juno
goes to Tammy and says she's sorry about
everyone and explains that no one ever
sees her there in this big house and
that she just wanted to be part of a
family group Tammy almost breaks you can
see little pity there but just not fully
she's just too cold we also see a moment
where Verna is shown through facial
recognition that she's been with all
these important people in the past that
are controversial so she's haunted these
people for years but he's still in out
about he's like look I saw Vic kill
herself and mine's still pushing Roger
like you know we met that woman that
night in the bar and it's tough some of
these scenes with Lenor and myy knowing
what's going to happen with myy and it's
sad she says I love you to Lenor they're
watching The Raven from 1935 with the
swinging pendulum scene which is going
to foreshadow Freddy's death and you get
a little Gerald's Game Easter egg you
see it in the Netflix queue when they're
watching which was cool and you see when
Freddy is with Mory he's like how long
are you effing him he won't even give
her a chance she's trying to just talk a
little bit but he still wants to make
her aware while drugging her and
torturing her like this it's so sick and
it's literally Ramsay Bolton from Game
of Thrones 2.0 with Theon was really
hard to watch I was like shocked it went
there with his character like threw me
off it was crazy now Tammy will see at
the speech Verna doing her speech as her
in the green outfit and Ruth cotage
junor her reactions here are Priceless
in the crowd to support her and Samantha
Sloan just kills it here as Tammy in the
scene and I love on the slides show
during the presentation it all changes
to
and then it shows a video of her role
playing and she throws the mic stand and
hits poor Juno right in the head that
was crazy but mine's there and sees
Verna knows what's going on and she
tries to grab her and she vanishes and
this is where back at the apartment
Verna is going to have some fun with
Tammy showing what it would have been
like of her apologizing to Bill and
she's like you still have time and I'm
sure In These Warnings ver is giving you
do these right things the time she's
saying to get a less gruesome death but
they never do they keep going through
with the bad choices and she said says
you might not believe me but this part
has nothing to do with you talking about
her father's Choice She's suffering for
of that death coming and Tammy just says
I effed it all up and you get this great
reflection of Verna in the glass on the
ceiling and you get this Matrix style
slow-mo and glass all comes down which
was brutal the most brutal part that was
her landing on her back on the bed into
the glass it was crazy kill but like I
said this wasn't my favorite episode at
that point I felt like I was kind of
getting sick of the format I was getting
too formulaic for me but I still really
enjoyed it I'm going to give this one an
8.7 okay now episode 7 The Pit and the
Pendulum is directed by Michael tumori
and written by Mike and Jamie Flanigan
shout out to Jamie Flanigan who has
watched my videos in comment before so
hope he's watching this time now this
was one of my favorite episodes I mean
this and the finale were the best to me
like Peak Mike Flanigan work here I love
it opens with that cat clock tail
swinging that Freddy as a kid is looking
at at his eventual Doom with the same p
Ang swinging sound going on in the
background really crazy now you see how
worried Annabell Le was about rodri
doing this ratting out the company and
that he'll be fired she's like I want
your word when it's done we can count on
your help and dupan says you can't blow
the whistle without a whistleblower but
he agrees that he'll help them and dupon
says to Roger both of us Lucky in one
way at least got good people at home who
love us anyway let's not let them down
this is exactly what Roger will do he'll
let them down and he'll choose the greed
money and the meline path over this
wonderful family he has and this will
really pay off in the finale when you'll
see that dupan is saying he is a more
rich person having a loving family and I
love that Auggie reflects back in the
present day saying that what made him
trust Ric is I trusted her so I trusted
you talking about Annabelle really good
writing there to explain that and he
says it sustained me a bit knowing you
lost her which was interesting and he
says there was no such thing as a good
Usher but there was one Annabelle Lee
Usher the only good Usher and you chased
her away but this is where Roger's like
no there is another good one that's
Lenor she had all the best of Annabelle
Lee without the broken heart so you
really get the payoff of the Edgar Alan
po feel of the stories with the
Annabelle Lee and with the hint of Lenor
and the Raven poem and how that's going
to wrap it's really just nice
storytelling now meline has this last
tail Mary Play to save the company for
her to take over and to have rodri kill
himself and move over the company to
Tech she's like it's the hardest thing
I've ever to say out loud so she's ready
to cut ties here with rodri and that
justifying like he's on his way out
anyway healthwise and in this episode
Freddy is in complete psychopath mode
he's got the wedding picture all over
the room with myy and he's like is that
how you see me toothless so you knew
that was coming and he's still obsessing
over where is the wedding ring also that
Freddy is the Swing Vote for the board
also meeting with the pendulum swinging
little nod there and he still hasn't
destroyed this building that Perry died
in now I love the scene where Juno is
talking about how like liadon is like
heroin and is calling Roger gal for all
his BS and this like I had talked about
before about the Frankenstein comparison
which was great writing
and Juno has the best SL she's like I'll
take three years of Hell over a lifetime
with you which is great so you're happy
that a character like Juno really lucked
out not being part of the Usher blood
here and actually gets a happy ending
and sticks up for herself now we'll see
Freddy will tell myy the lessons his
father taught him about you don't have
to be a tyrant but then you have to be
sufficiently brutal at least once to
establish Authority this is why he's
doing the tooth mutilation and he's like
you know what also we won't break our
bond you already cracked it which is the
other lesson to test a b
you crack a little but you don't break
it so just crazy using his father's
philosophies and what he's doing to myy
and you know now Mory saw at this moment
Verna there and at that point she really
intervened like this guy really deserves
the worst and switched the drugs what I
really loved is in the present when
Auggie is with rodri and he's saying
like oh that's probably Freddy with the
pendulum the clock swinging and that
he's going to show up make sure they get
the story right and Annabell Le and kid
Freddy appear and I love how it Blended
in the past when they come to when he's
going to testify they're like we had to
come here big day want to Fred to see
his daddy be a hero and you see now in
the present he's cutting his son cut in
half it's so interesting to me that
Roger was upset and reacted to Annabell
in the past that like was upset that she
brought the kids that day because he
knew what he was going to do he knew he
wasn't going to be this hero and it was
so hard to watch him just completely
betray Auggie here and you knew when
meline checked in him and said you got
this it was going to to go down the
other way and he even went so far to
accuse him of harassment so awful awful
stuff here by Roger and you see meline
immediately shakes hands with fortunado
and tells Annabelle as of today he's the
most important employee at that company
and Annabelle says Rodrick was going to
do the right thing he was going to be a
hero and she says back he did the right
thing you simpleton just ouch and meline
Spins it as he's instead the hero for
fortunado and she's like you're going to
be swimming in money promotions by
lunchtime tomorrow so this is the
choices make right as people you can
play the game and just do these people
hate just repeat what they're doing your
whole life and this show is great at
showing you not to do this to help
people to do good like a Lenor does like
an augi does like amori does it's always
a choice and I love the line she says
wow this really is you I thought you
only existed in the movies that was a
great great line but Annabelle says to
her you are so small meline and she'll
actually use that same line on the brick
she writes to Rufus when they kill him
you are so small meline also becoming a
Rufus herself and Annabelle was really
the right one in that saying here the
hypocrisy we're seeing now I love when
meline sees Verna when she's older and
verna's talking about she sees what mine
was is and could have been
shoulder-to-shoulder that was really
cool and she's like years ago I offered
you certainty tonight I offer you
Clarity and this is where she tells her
that her brother would have been a broke
poet and she'll then beautifully read Ed
Almo is the city in the sea and it's a
city ruled by death sin starts to sink a
place hell would worship so this really
is the House of Usher you see it in the
imagery of the show promotions so really
cool and this we'll also see Verna visit
Freddy before he dies in The warehous
with a wrecking ball on its way which
was awesome and she says he could have
been a pretty good dentist she's like
it's here Freddy I'm finally here and
he's making him watch it all come down
and the pedum start to swing over him
and she says there's other easier ways
this could have been done but then you
had to bring her home and then you had
to grab the pliers and I love love the
writing where she says to him about
Roger he did you wrong Freddy you only
ever wanted to be loved by him you only
ever wanted his approval and it's still
no excuse this is a line of the show and
sums it all up perfectly I love this
because you'll see a lot of people who
do wrong with this will justify their
poor upbringing as the reason why or
someone hurting them or harming them the
wrong way and thinking that's okay to
repeat that beh behavior when it's not I
almost wish the episode ended on this
with the pendulum swinging closer and
closer but they did have to get this
scene in where meline goes to rodri into
the world together out of the world
together and she wants him to kill
himself she's like I love you more than
anyone in the world and now I need you
to be a hero again referencing the time
when he betrayed ay and she said now
that's a legend that's a king you're
saving us all but she hears the bells at
the wall one last time and Verna is like
no way too easy so nice Cliffhanger
there and one of my favorite episod
episodes of all time in the Flanigan
universe so strong and great writing so
I'm giving this one a 9.5 and a great
job by Henry Thomas playing a character
I didn't even know he was good at
playing so really cool okay and now the
finale episode 8 The Raven this was
directed by Michael fuminari and written
by Mike Flanigan and key Sanchez this to
me was the Masterpiece episode and it is
really so close with me and bent neck
lady on my favorite alltime episodes of
the Flanigan universe this blew me away
and it makes me angry thinking about it
because this should be Emmy nominated
the show and they always screw her over
and it's time they take it more
seriously because there's nothing better
on TV than an episode like this so let's
jump into it so it opens with the Raven
calling and verna's talking to Roger
Kier after he tried to kill himself
she's like Millions Dead who knows how
many addicted can't accept your
resignation Maddie thought it was a
loophole to make this all stop him dying
and the jester jump scare here when he
stands up after seeing Verno was so
intense it got me really good and what's
huge is when we see the good choice
finally happened where Lenor says the
truth to Pim about her dad and stands up
to Pim and is like he's a ghoul he
mutilated my mom and will not go with
Pimp's plan to lie about it and cover
them up and you'll see even rogi says to
Pim later he she got that from Annabelle
the only other good Usher now was really
important is we learned that Annabelle
had cussy the kids and rodri hated that
so he bombed them with money when they
old enough and they would pick him
instead and it's great writing he's like
when I saw them I saw myself whatever of
their mother had been in there it was
gone it was killed by the money this is
such good writing and themes about money
and what it does to people and he tells
aie he saw Annabell at the funeral and
this ghost of Annabell says to him that
when people asked her how he took them
she said he's rich but she said you
didn't feed them though you starve them
but you weren't rich I look at you and I
see you the poverty of you and then
she's a great L she says maybe this is a
kindness in Disguise maybe they died in
their
childhoods crazy it's also interesting
we see she has damage in the back of her
head but we never get explained where
that was from and how exactly she passed
away but I thought it was so powerful
that when he's walking out of the church
that Annabelle is in the background
holding the children's coffins in her
hands just crazy and it leads up to him
seeing the gesture which you saw in
episode one and him collapsing and
seeing the Raven and saying it's time
and you see then in present day he
offers Auggie the drink from the jeweled
bottle remember the jeweled bottle is
what you drink best night of your life
or the night you're going to die in this
case we know it's the night he knows
he's going to die and he says sure I
can't tempt you and Augie's like No And
Roger's like wish I'd said that so that
regret right about making this deal with
Verna now see we get really explained
what happened here with the gester being
Rufus Griswald and what happened on New
Year's Eve and the choice that meline
and Roger made that would change their
lives forever this awful choice of
killing somebody and you see the line
Roofus says this bottle right here costs
more than a year of your former salary
this exact line again that Rodrick will
say to augat like he doesn't even
realized he's become the man he hated
and now we'll see the master plan happen
here the cyanide and mine seducing him
and their master plan would perfectly
fit in now rodri is hot shot that he
would fill in as CEO and then it makes
sense with the Pink Floyd Another Brick
in the Wall that started the show starts
playing again you see how it Ms up with
literally them putting bricks in the
wall and now where the gold starts to
happen is when we see when Verna talked
to them that night later with the deal
she's like so what would you do to make
your dreams come true what would you do
if I told you you can achieve all the
success you ever imagin lifetime of
luxury Comfort all the power but this is
also where Verna stuns them and brings
up them killing Rufus and she says what
if I could guarantee you could get away
with it you will be the king and queen
of fortunado your Birthright no legal
consequences your whole life explains
why the ushers never got charged for
anything as Auggie will say and she says
we are sitting outside of time and space
this is the moment luck meets
opportunity and this is where Roger's
like what are you going to say it costs
one of our souls or whatever and Verner
is like no such thing but even if it was
you already sold them tonight one brick
at a time so good and she says it won't
even go on your tab the price is
deferred let the Next Generation foot
the bill also great line because it's a
problem and a great theme we've had
about paying for the sins of our fathers
the generation before us and this is an
example of a choice they had a lot of
people don't care they act like they do
but they're thinking for themselves and
not even the future generation and then
she goes so that's the deal you get the
whole world and when you're done just
before you die Roger when you would have
died anyway your bloodline dies with you
and then when mine's like kind of trying
to say okay this is rodri's deal she's
like no you two die together you came
into this world together and you go out
of it together or No Deal which is great
and connecting to the twin theme here
and this is a great question she has
here where she's like the kids would
never want for anything life of luxury
where they could live a little longer
but struggle and she says what's more
loving 40 to 50 years of a gilded life
or 70 to 80 years of anxiety tribulation
and heartache and it's interesting that
meline says I say that's a good deal and
at first she's not totally believing
this whole thing and Roger doesn't even
hesitate and says I say that's a done
deal and even meline stunned how locked
in rodri is and she says I don't even
have kids this is his thing and he's
like you have a deal so this goes back
and pays off so well in this episode
when Roger owns in his confession like
he knew knew what he was doing he knew
it was going to cause this was just a
choice he decided to make and you see
Roger explains when they left that bar
that night it faded like a dream a
delusion shared by two and they never
talked about it again and then what's
also interesting is when Pim story is
wrapped up here with Verna and she sees
him at the House of Usher and she has a
little fun with him lets him think that
he captured her and she says one of my
favorite things about humans starvation
poverty disease you could fix all that
just with money and you don't and she
talks about all the vanity things we
instead choose use that money on and she
brings up Pim did not do anything when
his expedition group did bad to an
indigenous woman and he says we're a
virus I think and Verna says though but
so damn interesting had to go topside
had to see the ship go by with my own
eyes and you saw me too didn't you so
it's interesting that he did see Verna
at a time and it's interesting he says
what happens when the ushers are gone
you've enjoyed immunity your whole life
but it isn't yours it's theirs just
reflected and the offer is basically
he'll go to jail or not and he he wants
to know what's to catch what he's got to
offer and she says everyone loves
something and in that love is collateral
and he's like I have no collateral
collateral is leverage and I won't be
leveraged not going to seed that ground
this close to the end he's like I think
I'll play out my hand so he's again like
a Mike man trout type character arore
he's going out in the way just taking it
the fall here and that's why he's going
to you'll see go to jail now Lenor will
say to rodri not having fortune on anym
maybe it's a good thing for you that
place wasn't good grandpa and he says no
it wasn't but it was mine very Breaking
Bad type line there remind me of Walter
White towards the end and he says maybe
you'll make it good someday but she says
I say this with love let it go let it
all go you have more money than you'll
ever be able to spend let's put it to
work and try to fix things let go of
fortunado Leone it's not too late to fix
that fortunately it is for him but she
in her choices she's already made has
fixed things and her mother will fix
things which is great and that's the sad
part here when Lenor has to meet Verna
and she this is just where Carlo G is
just brilliant where she's like there's
a lot about my my job I love but there
are moments like these that bring me no
joy and she gives Lenor Peace of Mind in
her death about her mom and all the good
she will do and how many lives her mom's
foundation will save and in a decade it
will be millions and she says it gets
hard to count people she helps helps
others and they help others again going
to the steam about all these good
choices you make in helping someone just
pays it forward but she says this is the
part I want you to hear you did that
when you got her out of the house when
you defied your father you did that you
saved those people that choice you made
e goes through millions of lives I
thought you should know that the
complete opposite of the effect that
meline and Roger had where they affect
millions of lives in the other awful way
so really powerful stuff when she kills
her and I'm happy they honored the deal
with Verna and that it had to happen
that way and that they didn't make it
sappy and somehow she lives kind of
thing with Lenor so really really paid
off now what's great is you really feel
that Edgar omo feeling and the directing
here by Michael fenari is incredible
when he brings in The Raven poem and we
see the Raven at night and how much this
affected rodri losing Lenor and he'll
never again when they're saying never
more see Lenor again and we get that
reveal that it's an AI bot of Lenor that
mad was making is what he's been texting
and just the lighting and the dead Lenor
haunting him with the Raven was so
awesome and when he goes to the
boardroom he's got all his dead children
and his grandchild in front of him and
Verna shows the bodies fall behind him
that he ca she's like that's your legacy
now we'll get to see before rodri met
with in the current timeline Auggie he
met meline at the house and they have a
toast and M's like he always said it was
You and Me Against the World said we
changed the world we did didn't we and
he's like we did and they're talking
about how he brought the treasures there
the same as the pharaoh's did this
carcass of a house is is our tomb so all
we need is the dressing and but you see
how man's like we built a life a
privileged life out of nothing but dirt
and Trauma so again this is her
justifying like yeah they did the right
thing cuz they had it tough I love the
lion she's like would we have done
anything different if we believe that
woman in the bar was real interesting
and then you see how it justifies
everything you don't want to look at on
and don't buy it you don't want to get
addicted don't abuse it they're mad
because we made it available and
desirable and she's like Supreme Court
is more concerned with dick pills over
woman's rights and a lot what she'll go
on to say about consumers isn't wrong
but again this is the theme of the show
where it doesn't justify the wrongs of
what they're doing a wrong and a wrong
doesn't make a right and she's saying
how they invented us she's like so I say
we stand tall proud brother and she's
like let's not hide in the basement like
we got something to be ashamed of not us
you and me against the world she says
don't care if it's death herself she
wants mine Usher she's gonna have to
look at me straight in the eyes just
amazing moment for just now this alltime
villain of meline Usher she's like
really like rodri's the villain of the
show but M user is like really the true
true villain of the show and then he
poisoned her and he gives her the
goddess Barrel that's been hinted at the
whole show of toer it and literally cuts
her eyes out puts her eyes in but the
craziest thing was she was not not dead
this is the same mistake he made with
his mother and I love how that leads her
to coming upstairs but he says too
Auggie I'm sorry for all the times that
inconvenience you may not have been
perfect but you can't say we didn't
change the world how many people can say
that at the end I promis My Confession
here it is I knew deep down in the
witching hour I knew I knew I would
climb to the top of the tower on a pile
of corpses and we told them it was about
soothing the world's pain that's the
biggest lie we told you can't eliminate
pain there's no such thing as a
painkiller and imagine if we put that on
the bottle I bet I could have still sold
it incredible incredible writing
incredible moment this just sold the
whole show for me here that he owned it
here and he knew what he was doing it
wasn't like this thing where we figured
it out later like just crazy stuff here
when Auggie saw meline it was just
intense and you see she chokes rodri
like the mom choked the boss again
showing he kind of fit those shoes of
the boss too and the House of Usher
comes crumbling down now my favorite
shot of a show in years I'm not just
saying this in of hor was Verna on top
of of that house that is how you do har
with the lightning and her eyes glowing
as the Raven and all ye seeing her on
top of the house crumbled of Usher and
the Raven calling leaving incredible
that is why I say this is also a
masterpiece not only the writing not
only the acting but that visual horror
shot there what you're feeling in that
moment feeling like Auggie seeing that
was unbelievable and unreal like
incredible and we see that Juno
completely dissolved fortunado every
dollar went to addiction help and she
weaned herself off lione like I said she
gets a happy ending Pimp's arrested some
justice there but Remains the only
conviction of fortunado pharmaceutical
case none of the ushers cuz that was the
deal and then dupan has this great
monologue at the end to the Roger grave
where he says opioid epidemic is with us
now you tattooed on the world but
they're trying to take it down and he
puts the recorder in front of the grave
and he says it don't matter why you did
any of it in the end I don't care why
you did it we don't want your confession
rationale explanation goodbye Roger I'm
going home to my husband my kids their
kids I'm the richest man in the world
you know that incredible and a great
message and yeah it doesn't matter
matter what your philosophy is your
confession why you did something like
you still did it and you had that choice
and it's wrong so that was really good
and that he had the true riches with his
family and Verna AKA The Raven shows up
to Auggie which is awesome and we'll see
she puts the tokens of death of each
child and the grandchild and rajer K mes
on the graves and it ends with the r and
flying away to end the poem absolute
Masterpiece of an episode so it's a 10
for me and when I averaged out all the
scores of the Season I'm going to give
it a 9.2 it comes to and it's like like
this close to haunting Phil house for me
where haunting and Phil house will still
be my number one just because of how
many Masterpiece episodes are just in
that one season but this had the best
end and the best story full around and I
feel like a lot of people like this the
best because people were complaining
about maybe too sappy some of his other
work just doesn't have the sap and it
really my favorite thing it got rid of
those overlong monologues and look what
came of it just amazing level so
definitely better than blind Manor
definitely better than midnight mask for
sure definitely better than Midnight
Club so this is number two for me right
after haunting I mean this is an
incredible show and that finale I would
say honestly is tied with bent neck lady
for me for my favorite episode of the
Flanigan universe so I hope you enjoyed
my review of this I love reviewing his
work cuz he's incredible and once in a
lifetime toal we get to enjoy he's the
goat for me now of horor and has passed
Stephen King in my eyes so I I'm just
blown away by this and I can't wait to
see what he does with Amazon and he does
with the Dark Tower series so let me
know what you thought I want to hear all
your thoughts everything you thought
about this show in detail I really
appreciate it and subscribe so you don't
miss one of my reviews I really can use
all the support I can get and if you
like X-Men I have an X-Men Channel out
X-Men Trove hit that subscribe but on
that as well and I'll see you next time